today I'm going to discover Berlin by
bus and it's not just any old bus it's
route 100 the city's most famous line
it's a cheap ride and you can see a lot
of interesting sights we start off at
Zoo station but first we need to buy a
ticket I would suggest you get a day
ticket for 7 euros so you can use the
Ubon and buses as often as you want and
another little suggestion most people
think the bus leaves here from zoo
station that's why it's always so full
but if you just go around the corner
into hats alley you'll see that there's
nobody at this bus stop I get the best
seat on the bus upstairs front row
nothing blocking my view
once the others have joined us at Zoo
station we can get going
may I introduce another Lucas he's from
the silent past the Memorial Church and
the zoo we drive through the west of the
city the bus 100 was the first bus line
connecting East and West Berlin after
reunification it's a hit with tourists
we pass palace Bellevue the official
residence of Germany's president the
house of world cultures and the
Reichstag there's always lots going on
here outside the Reichstag on one side
we pass the high stock the German
parliament and on the other side is the
Brandenburg Gate also a popular photo
opportunity I had a chat to sum up the
many tourists posing in front of it are
you taking a picture it's one of the
world's most famous landmarks and it's
good to remember a place not everyone
has the chance to come here and see it
it's something that's kind of
stereotypically German but I think it
there is a lot more to it and so I'm
hoping that we can take pictures now and
learn some more and then look back and
make a personal connection to history
German history that's pretty
sophisticated
I try to be sophisticated I'm not sure
if it always works ok why do you take a
picture in front of the Brandenburg Gate
so I think it's the done thing to take a
photo here we're from a village and it's
my friend's first time in Berlin yeah
I hop back on the number of 100 bus
it continues down hunter Dean Linton
which right now is a huge building site
it doesn't look like the Magnificent
Boulevard that it usually is the reason
they're currently building a new
underground line this building is the
new city palace the palace is due to
open in 2019 it might not look that
impressive yet but I'll take you to the
info box so you can imagine what it will
look like once the construction is
complete the entry is free
this is what Berlin looked like in 1900
with the palace at the center of the
city the palace was heavily damaged
during World War two and instead of
rebuilding it the former East German
government blew it up in 1950
discussions on whether the palace should
be rebuilt or not continued for years
after the German reunification the
people supporting the reconstruction
came out on top
the facade elements are being rebuilt
financed entirely through the Nations
the new old palace is planned to be
finished by 2019 it's called the
homeward fall in the infobox rooftop
cafe I try one of Berlin's specialities
death Nereids so this is a ballina visor
with a shot green is with a double syrup
called luck meister red is raspberry
doesn't depend both classics you fill
them up with rice beer I know that from
childhood that's a classic right exactly
wheat beer with syrup typical Berlin
people used to drink Berliner Weisse on
its own
then they started mixing it in the 19th
century red or green let's see which
one's nicer
well I definitely like the green one
better now it's the last lack of the bus
roof 100 passed the red city hall and
st. Mary's Church the popular tourist
bus line ends at Alexanderplatz but my
journey isn't over the TV tower at 368
meters it's the tallest structure in
Germany
and the world clock also in
Alexanderplatz is a popular meeting
point for people in Berlin but can you
actually tell what time it is what time
is it in Argentina no idea in Argentina
let me see capital of Argentina Buenos
Aires so what time is it
that's unfair 11:00 a.m. right see this
is because they sunny has to go a little
bonus iris allora
11:00 all right that's perfect okay you
got it
my last stop for today a beach bar in
Berlin city centre this is where people
who can dance meet and it's also for
people like me who want to learn how to
dance I choose the beginners course
first without music Foxtrot is here with
music also no problem English would have
lunch now with a partner she's called
Josie by the way we're both naturals
aren't we them so what marks do we get
hey that's not so bad
now it's time for the Advanced Course
and that's a whole different league I've
only been dancing for an hour so I might
not be that much of a hopeless case I'll
keep practicing and we'll enjoy this
summer evening in Berlin bye-bye